you can't allow outside people change
who you are so you must also continue to
give opportunity other people even
though the last person you gave an
opportunity did you wrong and you got to
understand there a occupational hazards
this is a job and it ain't just about
jokes it ain't about funny it's about
your work ethic you're a businessman
you're not a businessman and you must be
your best manager you you must be your
best agent you
and like he said hard work tastes well
hot breath what's goody hot breath the
verse welcome back to Hot Breath the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros I am your host comedian Joel buers
and our guest today is the first comic
Dave Chael has ever produced a Netflix
special for their relationship started
way bizak in the early 90s when my man
on the show today actually started his
own comedy club because the other comedy
clubs would not book him this is is just
one of the many obstacles he's had to
overcome in his 30 plus year career most
recently he was about to achieve a
lifelong dream of having his own sitcom
that got delayed due to the writer
strike at one time in his career he even
thought about quitting but we are all
better for it and today we're going to
get into his
undeniable standup game this is a man
who Jerry Seinfield called a machine
this is a man who Dr Dre called from a
yacht
after seeing his comedy special that New
York Times voted as the funniest of the
Year ladies and gentlemen hot Brethren
and sister welcome to the hot breath of
verse Nathaniel pooy earthquake strowman
how
Dam you got
everybody everybody that's poy told you
that was P that's that that is saw
strowman earthquake your government out
there well first of all let me tell you
thank
you um your review of my
special when you said what you said so
eloquently about joke per minute and
everything I came me I'm not lying to
you from comic to Comic man to man just
human being to human being I was I was
just late I came into my own radio show
I showed it to my woman I said look at
this this review and I say baby she like
who is he I say he's a man who watches
comedy this is when you dealing with
someone who's in the business and then I
had to of course you always got to give
your woman a sell he's like a skip
Bist you know I'm saying dedicate his
life to the genre of what we do and will
him to give us this is is outstanding
then once I told him that um I told her
that uh she understood and I I'm I
always wanted to personally tell you
thank you for that wow I appreciate it I
mean as as a comedian myself and
watching your special and just like
you're watching it almost like well why
even bother if that's where the bar is
it's like I believe we clocked it at 14
laughs per minute I mean and these are
house laughs I learned it from Steve
Harvey how to do it wouldn't been a part
of what is a joke what is a degree of a
joke how you scale a joke and um once he
I learned that from him then I just
compacted together to to for the
accumulated effect what did he teach you
well oh he has a gring system for a joke
number four joke is just a filler joke a
three joke is a joke that works sometime
um partly two jokes now number two jokes
it'll work 5050
a number one joke is a joke that'll work
anywhere I don't care if you at a
funeral you in a hospital somebody die
the ones so when you do a special you
want to put all ones and that's why it's
called a comedy special because it
supposed to be special and the best way
to make it special is put it on so what
I did was put all my ones and then I
just compacted them together till I turn
it into a Uzi
yeah you know what I mean I've been
doing that all that's that's just my
style but when you um comedy special and
I'm just it's so great place in my life
personally emotionally financially you
know where who I am what I am know how
to to regulate this gift you know they
ain't no a anxiety with it I don't have
have um I don't have no uh nervousness
about it no expectation no limitations
just know how to do it and no
competition because you're dealing with
something that's subjective so the only
competition is yourself so you what you
do is try to get the best that you are
and then film it that's where I'm at
yeah I feel sometimes I feel like before
I go on stage I'm like oh I need because
it sounds like your mindset is no
there's no expectation I'm is going to
be me I'm at a mind set of like oh I got
to get something I got to go out there
and kill I got to get the laughs from
the audience yeah I I mean you still
have that uh expectation and that um
what you need to to achieve because you
know I mean you know occupational hazard
you go in there I don't need nothing you
hear
Boo and [__] but how you process to get
to that point is different now I don't I
don't that EX anxiety of oh man I got to
this and this I've learned how to
harness this gift and now I you know
this what I need to do this what I need
to do this what I need to eat this where
who I need to separate and if I do all
of that the gift will come out of shelf
and you have no you know level of uh um
the word I'm looking for expectation but
to yourself and if you do the best you
can do it'll translate to the audience
you know what I mean yeah so it will and
and then you'll be amazed damn I was my
best self today I was I but you still
better than the average person that
doing it and they don't
know they don't they don't know cuz you
you're not in a group you're an
individual artist so you know long as
you put that excellence in it that way
for me that's at work it took me a long
time time to get to that I think I just
got it the last six or seven years cuz
anxiety used to be the [__] it' be back
my okay time to go on you cuz I don't
get to the to the venue till 10 minutes
before it's time for me to go on so I
don't I don't have no set set so I have
to isolate myself from everybody else
because if I start talking to him her I
lose my train of thought get out there
[__] around be talking about him and her
you know I have to isolate myself but
now I know how to be able to talk to him
and her and still be able to get on
there and do what I want to do you never
have like a set list or anything you no
go out there yeah I never uh have never
physically right I mentally right uhhuh
what I do is I um I come up with a
u say you say a bit you know what I mean
and you just elaborate on it and you
just keep on it's like what I like to
say it's a uh the truth that turns into
a lie you you know what I mean you see a
truth of it and you just expand on it
you know you see a dude get jumped and
one dude beat him up by the time I tell
you a story it was eight people on them
and they slammed them to the ground and
he dragged them all the way down the
street and all of a sudden he CED for
his mama none of that happened yeah the
only thing happened he got his ass
whooped you know what I mean so it's a
it's a truth that you elaborate on and
it just expands and expands and expands
and I see it so when I see it mentally I
just see the picture and talk it out of
it I don't rehearse the word
I see the picture of the joke you know I
I I see what you know the the whole
scenario of it and then I'll just tell
what I see so like from your special
legendary like the January 6th joke
where just
the and I left out a part of it because
and I'm so mad at myself because I left
out the part I supposed to been John
wicking that [__] p p p go damn
John P P yeah but see I seen it so just
think yourself okay I'm a security
guard all of a sudden these people are
coming up here all my friends are mad at
me how [__] first of all your a black
man being a security guard that's I
already look down on you then you
protecting some people up here that
don't in in the hood feeli they don't
give a [__] about them because it's the
United States
congressman and on this day this
beautiful day Trump's support was just
rushing and you call your friend man I
told you you should have got this job
I'm shooting Trump supporters on the
clock you know what I mean so if you you
see so you take that and you take that
on it just think of you in that scenario
you you put that mentally in your
scenario and then you just play it all
out what would you be
doing you Ain going use your gun give it
to
me people what you doing saving
democracy you feel what I'm saying now
you see the whole movie and you just
telling what you see the movie you seen
and that's how I do my comedy and
sometimes I forget a scene of the movie
like I did on a special because we
didn't they we shot that one take Quake
we just took it we didn't do no editing
it was just straight you know we just
did it like that and I and never until I
got to watch it with cev and the rest of
when we did the premiere I said God damn
I forgot to put the John W
I love even at your level that like in
our Comics mind there's always something
we get off stage we're like ah yeah you
know what I mean because you sit there
but see if you see in a movie if if I
try to think put John Wick in there
it'll throw everything off you see what
I'm saying like it's like a [__]
editing it you're like oh way now get
back up take it from there then the
division is gone yeah so you have to
tell what you see at that particular
time and let it go and be happy with it
so did to develop that joke do you see
January 6th happen and then you're like
oh man if I worked there I would I'd be
shooting everyone and then you take it
to the stage and start expanding on it
well for me to get to that one I just
looked at the restraint that all the
cops had with them that they usually
didn't have with people in my community
you know what I mean yeah they was able
to um
commence and
inflict far
worser violence po police officers and
only one was dealt with with deadly
force you know and um in my community
you move your hand the wrong way you
make a gester towards the
police and you know they they use their
discretion of using deadly force and say
in their defense you know I fear for my
life
so I took that mentality and applied to
there see what I'm saying so I'mma use
the
same methodology y'all use in our
community for them you see what I'm
saying but I understand that because you
the people who was them that was coming
there was them they was they recognized
so you have more restraint for people
that you have familiarity
to yeah so I was like I didn't have no
familiarity with you so I would been
when you were in my community and that's
how I came to the formalization p p p I
would have shout all y'all that's what
have came what are you doing saving
democracy you know that type of thing
that's how I came to it yeah because
clearly it's it's a joke you really
cared about because even at the end of
the credits of the special that's like
the last thing you hear as well it like
plays that little sound bite again I
don't know I
mean I watched that special once twice
at the most I'm hard watching myself
stuff because I look at it like damn I
supposed to you know what I mean so it
did well it did far it did exact put it
this way it did exactly what I could I
pray that it would do so we was talking
off air before I have feel an I'm not an
ungrateful person and then to criticize
something that did so well for me would
have been ungrateful so I don't watch
you know what I mean you know what I
mean cuz the the critique come in and
then the little they like you ungrateful
bastard you know you're so afraid that
you might go down and lose that blessing
that you have so I don't watch it
creatively but I watched it when we had
the uh Premiere off of it and what it
did in one more a couple more times with
my fiance and other than that I just say
all
right this next when we going to do we
gonna make sure it's even better I'm
looking forward to that hey you're doing
that with Dave again doing it with Dave
again we're going to do it in Atlanta
the birthplace of my comedy I was born
in Washington DC that is my birthplace
where I was born but the birthplace of
me doing um my career of my standup of I
wouldn't be here as a comedian if it
wasn't for Atlanta the I mean Atlanta
I'm still eating off of all the love
Atlanta has done for me Atlanta showed
me so much in the early 90s by my club
was the hottest club they came to see me
and all the comedians would come there
was just beautiful and I
learned everything about my craft in
theant and I will always be again
grateful to lat to atanta I had to do
the first special in DC because that's
my hometown but my second one it
couldn't be nowhere else but ATM dude
every I always ask a comic on here like
there worst bombing story there worst
booze story I can't tell you how many
have happened at your Uptown Comedy
Club there are so many that are like
well I was at Uptown I was like say less
I know where this is going that sounds
like that whole era right there was just
like legendary yeah because we um shout
out to the comedy act theater shout out
to
559 we was
um we was we was heavy weights in the
south in the world world we was we BR
everybody there and we you know we set a
standard see we it's certain uh
communities are educated in comedy
Cleveland is Atlanta is Chicago DC
certain places they they I mean they STS
they they know it and we
raised the expectations so you just
couldn't come down there with knock
knock jokes and then um I didn't make it
easy for on me I 11 and didn't give him
the
mic you understand you know what I mean
and that's from the time I was really on
man I was I was having my man I was
enjoying Atlanta and everything I was I
was a rock star Rick James I was it was
beautiful you know and um we was funny
raising the roof off of it and certain
people
underestimated you know you know what it
took step on that stage and the
difference between us and New York was
they didn't
boo
because you didn't we ain't give you
enough time we gave they booed because
you just wasn't good
at yeah I mean that didn't mean you
wasn't a great comic you need to be
better than you are tonight and you know
that's that's that's what we did yeah
because I think in speaking of New York
I think you had an experience at the
Apollo where you had to walk off right
yeah I wasn't going to let them boo me
my ego I'd be damn I heard a
[__] cough I said that's it good
night you know what I mean because I
what we do is subjective my tell
comedians all the time you know no
matter how funny you is including myself
somebody gonna find you not funny you
just pray to God all the [__]
don't show up tonight you know yeah yeah
yeah and that's what you do and you
should never put it shouldn't especially
for comedian put you in the place you
have to prove you're funny see that's
the different from the club we give you
our club gave you opportunity and you
proved that you wasn't worthy in my
humble opinion Apollo you had to come
over here and prove to them and I ain't
got [__] to prove to you you know I mean
I don't I don't I'm not in the proing
game what do you think about because I
know you always love to help upand
cominging comedians yes how do you feel
about this new like I mean the the
social media game and now Comics are
almost chasing Clips more than like
actually developing on stage how do you
feel about that as an OG I don't have no
problem with it I mean I appreciate um
any um vehicle or platform that help you
connect with your uh with your crowd
with your your clientele uh with your
fans all I say to Comedians and I always
say it to them you know what I mean to
say you're a comedian you cannot omit
the process when it comes to be a
comedian and that's the stage uh and I
tell them it's not how many followers
you have it's how many comedians you can
follow if you can't get behind another
comedian follow him after a long night
then you're not over here with me until
you can able to stand on that stage and
let four five people rip and then they
call your name me you take it to a
higher level then you can't call
yourself comedian I don't care what you
say you say you call yourself but
eventually sometime somewhere they're
going to put you in a room and ask you
what you think and what's funny and
you're not going to be a to rehearse it
yeah you're not going to be to do a clip
you're not gonna be say cut that let's
edit that you ain't gonna be to do that
you're gonna have to sell you and you're
doing yourself a
disservice if you don't um achieve that
objective or get over that hurdle while
you also doing the internet um thing and
it's a lot of comedians that's doing it
one comes to mind is uh DC Young Fly um
he went on tour with us and um with the
ogs man and I could tell you he could
have made a lot more money than being
with us but he wanted to also achieve
that because he needed that and he has
it now he need needed to see this is how
you need to do it this is weakness and
um yeah so I don't have nothing against
them I mean listen
man you can't compete with something
that's
subjective you understand what I'm
saying yeah I mean there's no such thing
who's the funniest because like I said
previous one person might find you funny
other person might not find you funny
you just need to find your audience and
have them come see you hell would be in
number one right here in my studio right
here got Kevin horse name everywhere up
here and this Quake house is this
channel is everything you know what I
mean if you was a inferior or something
[__] God this [__] name everywhere I
know it's this station no you never want
to be number one because that's not the
objective of being number one cuz again
it's objective you just want to be in
the top 52 cuz it's 52 weeks in the year
you understand so if Kevin hars in the
lad on week one they going to need
somebody week two they gonna need
somebody week three they gonna need
somebody week four so hell will be in
one you just want to be in the top 52
that you in the rotation of a comedy
club I tell com comedians that all the
time and you want to root for that
person he's about to be the first
billionaire comedian ever so that mean
he has opened up doors with the
possibilities Like Rappers that it's a
billion doll dude in this profession
doing comedy i' be damn if this man make
a billion dollars man and I don't make
at least one% yeah 10% that's $100
million yeah so how is he doing it inste
hating on him duplicate what he doing
unless you feel that you're not talented
he is then that's your problem that's
your problem that's a mindset thing
that's a mindset because it's subjective
he founds his audience I never say I
never ever
felt in seeing any of my peers all my
any of them be in
arenas and
felt inferior cuz I never took quantity
over quality just because you have
18,000 I got 18 don't mean you have a
better show than I do that mean more
people heard about yours and I need to
get a a better job of getting them to
come see me like you did for yours I
never looked at it in life has always
been my strongest point is perspective
my perspective has always been that and
it's better to hand or come there and do
business with how did you do this Kevin
Hart is one of the hardest working
[__] in the world I told him
ain't no way I go work like you sh you
can tell I ain't got no money because
I'm still working when I get some money
I'm quitting I a sh I'm enjoy this [__]
I'll be damn you GNA see me on
everything what have you learned from
working so closely with them
the hustle is real game is real Envy is
real toxic is
real you can't
allow outside people change who you are
if you're a good person and you get
burned by being a good
person you allow them to win twice if
that bad person change you who you are
so you must also continue to give
opportunity to other people even though
the last person you gave a opportunity
did you wrong and you got to understand
there an occupational hazard that um
people are gonna come after you when you
ain't do nothing to them and you
must you know what I'm saying this is a
job and it ain't just about jokes it
ain't about funny it's about your work
ethic you're a businessman you're not a
businessman and you must be your best
manager you you must be your best agent
you and like he said hard work tastes
well you know tastes good and you know
can't [__] on him if he getting up 8
o'clock in the morning doing 252,000
situps and you still l in the bed till
noon you know what I mean the man is
working he's putting his work in and you
know so that's what I learn you know
hard work tastes well would have been
some of the like the ups and down of
your career for doing it for over 30
years I mean you're like you're doing it
now like you've got you've got the shine
but imagine I know in my own career I've
had some moments where I was like oh
this is it and then it's not it you know
like what are some of those hurdles you
had to overcome careerwise it really
hasn't been to many them disappointment
mine's more been personal with people I
associate myself with you don't want to
get into personally speaking that AR the
arrogance of saying I shouldn't be
around that person cuz I was that person
that before I became this person you
know what I mean but certain people are
down there for a reason and you you uh
you can't associate with it if I had to
do it all over again it's a lot of
people that I wouldn't invest time into
I'd have just associated with them I
wouldn't allow them to share my dream I
allow them to witness it I would have um
I wouldn't I wouldn't have felt that we
were a team out of treating them as an
individual you know inviting to the
party but never to the board run invited
them you know to the after party but
never to the scheming of but you know
but it's a lesson learn you know and I
don't care who they are you you you know
you have to be careful who you allow to
share your dream be a part of your dream
and you feel in my community you feel
obligated because they was around you
when you came to you know the agreement
or realize that you are the one God
picked to do this and you want to be
like metaphor I can speak this us it
really ain't us you know it's a you God
put you and you must do you and Steve
Harvey said very much so everybody that
you meet ain't meant to go where you
going you know what I mean they're like
boosters in the spaceship you know on on
the shuttle they supposed to take you as
far and then jettison them them rockets
off for you to go farther and I didn't
learn that I was still trying to Bo take
the boosters with me to Mars yeah and
that kept me from going to monks and
once I jettison them off then I took off
so you were just you would get an
opportunity with them be distracted by
these other well distracted turning it
over to people that wasn't qualified to
handle the moment uh allowing people to
speak for me that I had no reason other
than just be there to be a witness not a
spokesman um aipia I mean a lot of
things um contaminating my thoughts you
know what I mean if you look at any
celebrity I personally speaking if I if
I had to say it most celebrities that
get in trouble is really not them 100%
it's the people that around there that
encouraged them give them you know put
the put the put the few on the fire it
might be a spark there make it a fire
and you know because they don't have
that your best interest um they haven't
grown their way of dealing with a a
problem is still the way they deal with
it when they was in inner city or at
their level they're not looking from the
perspective of who you are you can't
deal with it that way so took me a while
to learn that but now I got it and then
you know but see I never feared it
because I knew I always
assess who the man was in our profession
and I always KN you I was good enough
yeah I love he talk about comedy just
like I KN it is you know what I mean I
knew you know I knew I was good enough
and the money never goes down you know
I'm saying I think I heard you say quote
it was it was something about like um I
don't I don't need to be your favorite
comedian I I need your favorite comedian
to know me so when the their fans find
me they know what comedy really is it
was something like that of well what I
said is if you don't think I'm
funny go ask whoever you think is funny
am I funny now if you think he's funny
he's telling you I'm funny then it's you
yeah cuz that's the person you look up
to now go as go you said and F so yours
must be something else than it just say
you don't like me then I'll take that
yeah but not funny come on let's be real
I tell too many jokes too many quality
jokes in in a
compact just together of of content more
than anybody there's no way you're not
going to find one of these not hilarious
they'll go all the way through some
people special only got one good hot
thing all the way through one hot bit
you understand we 20 25 bits in the 30
come on man you sitting there you ain't
find none of these but yet you say this
dude is funny so I'm not even going to
argue with you I'm going ask you go ask
him he like no he the man then I'm ask
now your man said I'm the man
so I you not well that's that's what I
hear you're like yeah I just go on stage
and talk and then I'm like well I'm like
sitting down and like trying to write
jokes and I'm trying to like be
structured and all this then I'm looking
at you're I'm getting not to compare I
guess it's all subjective but it is like
man is there like another way it's like
the confidence I guess well I tried your
way and it didn't work mhm Steve helped
me with that true story um we riding in
Atlanta it was Atlanta or Dallas and I'm
right the [__] you
doing I said I'm trying to write this
get this bit he grab a paper SP it throw
it out to through the paper and the [__]
you he said your [__] comes out already
don't you lie these comedy club Owners
or manag or other Comics to make you do
a
process that you don't have to do it you
have the gift yours come out
already so go with
that and once he told me that it was all
over there he told me that he told me
when he told me I was it was a rap after
that I just went up there and started
seeing it and running with it and just
could just go with it that's why I tape
every show I have taped every show I've
ever done because I supposed to be
disciplined enough to go back say oh I
said that I work on
that no I just say something else next
day feel you're almost following a
feeling more than like words on stage
it's almost like what you're feeling in
that moment yeah I might um you know
long as I keep my environment sterile
and um keep my mind you know that's why
I don't take any calls like for hours
three hours before the show and talk to
nobody just keep it in there and
um I keep it in and then I say I want to
talk about this I want to talk about
that and then I just elaborate that's
why I will always do comedy clubs
because it allows me to write there you
know what I mean I can write on say you
can't write when you doing a theater or
Arena you don't play with 18,000 people
or 6,000 people [__] around get
booed you can you can control 400 people
yeah 00 people you know what I mean you
could you could search for it you could
you could you can draw it out you know
what I mean you can you can you can
bring it out and then once you bring it
all out then you get a thought from here
a thought from there and then you can
pack it together and then it becomes one
thought and
just it's the whole set then you look up
and say all right I got 40 minutes
Knockouts you understand what I'm saying
do you think are you going to do like
the your AR set was 37 minutes are you
going to do that length again you think
or I want to but I been asking your I
want to do that but I don't the money
that next G pay me they gonna say I got
a do hour I think they I'mma I'mma try
to get away with 30 because I don't need
an hour man I already set the St I mean
standard for 37 minutes I'm really going
to try to do
37 but it's really not up to me to be
quite honest with you I prefer to do 37
cuz I did it but they need me put the
other 23 on it and and you know and they
making sure it's right and they said in
ex chain for the money we giving you sir
you got to give us a whole hour and I
say yes sir just Netflix whatever you
say you know I mean I ain't got no
problem with it just air it and let it
be yeah the the money it's funny the
money and comedy they can be um hard to
combine you know but what you mean tell
me about I mean making money in comedy I
mean you know some of us I remember
coming up driving 12 hours for 50 bucks
and things like that you know what I
mean coconuts oh yeah yeah down there
Florida um oh what Brian Soo did all
those yeah I've been coconuts the
holiday in with a food and beverage
manager works with the co with the
comedy club promoter you have to sit
there and entertain all the people
that's in Fort Walton Beach or Dayo
Beach Florida that stay in the holiday
in and they come now for comedy night
$50 for the uh feature 150 for the
headliner 25 for the uh MC and you
couldn't tell us nothing we leave from
there go to Lakewood Cal I mean Lakewood
Florida then down to Miami then come up
to Hilton Head South Carolina and um
yeah beautiful beautiful time beautiful
when you weren't making money it was a
beautiful time
well I was the money
Justified where I was at in my career
but the money for me is all it Justified
more than anything exactly what it does
for me now it's
Independence I made enough money that I
didn't have to work for somebody else
you know what I mean you put that 150
together with that under 150 show I was
clearing like $1,000 a week and my
friends who was in the military you know
they got out the military was working
for other people back in thing they was
making $1,200 every two weeks so I was
beating them you know what I mean and I
was doing what I love to do so it gave
me the independence and I that's the
importance of money with me it gives me
the independence to do you know to be
able to do what I want to do and not
answer to anybody else yeah so the money
was the money since the day I got in
comedy has always been great for me and
another cliche not a cliche another um
lesson I learned from Steve Harvey was
uh never let never let money not be the
reason for you not getting on
stage never let money he always said he
would said because we get paid by the
days so Friday just say Friday June TI
you a $10,000 comedian but they only got
eight if you ain't got another 10 coming
in you better get that eight because
June 10th is not coming again because
you get paid by that Friday so what you
GNA stay home and I get no money cuz you
needed 10 or you GNA go ahead and pick
that eight up and you never know who's
in that audience that might bring
another tent that seed from there so
once he taught me that I have always say
you know and I have taught all the time
you know we we we turn nothing now so if
if we have something else then we'll say
no but ain't nothing else and you near
you near the N ballp we'll do it so it
fluctuates with the price so you never
let money be the reason why you do not
get on Stak I just said no to a gig
yesterday because the price wasn't right
well if you I mean if it's not don't get
me wrong you know it's C it got to be
close yeah now insult you know what I
mean [__] came to me and say Qui
we got $2,000 I I don't work for $2,000
I can't I just $2,000 quality of life
What It Takes I'm then on it but if you
if my retail is a certain price and you
off
2,000 then I I look at it man we got to
go get that you know what I mean we got
to go get that
and uh so it shouldn't never be the
reason you have other reason and that's
insulted the foney just was the the
reason it was insulting but the money
ain't the reason why you didn't do it it
was insulting for a person that do so
that's the clarity on it you shouldn't
work you
know you because that could hurt you
even more you know if you if you allow
people cuz they'll feel he'll take it
and then they'll start playing on that
so it has to be around the the ballpark
which you usually will you know if
you're a $20,000 a night comedian they
got 175 you should take the 17 cuz 175
pay something yeah for sure you
understand yeah yeah nothing I'll take
that yeah okay I remember that that I I
think as a young comic they've got to
take whatever whenever though like that
stage time is like that's where yeah you
do but you when you're a young comic you
also want to position
yourself with growth and what I mean
is with this okay I know who I am now I
know my art I know how to tell a joke so
my quantity of shows have to move to
quality of shows who am I doing the
shows with who is the promoter am I
going to get more out of there than the
personal satisfaction that I know I'm
funny is this going to be in front of
people or something that could prepare
to another bigger show you have to make
those kind of decisions once you get to
the point that you understand you know I
got this I don't need you know like a
boxer I don't need to just be fighting
to be fighting I need meaningful fights
I need fights that's going to prepare me
to get the belt the championship
metaphorically speaking that's what you
want to do in a person such as your
position now that you known and you got
a grip so this great talent you have how
can I get more meaningful shows how can
I do a show uh who uh man got a Latino
audience he's big and I can get on the
show with him so his audience can see me
Diverse your [__] go ahead and do a show
with quig with his audience you want to
sit here andair yourself with a
different people so you can get a vast
uh group to come see you your your
mentality said yeah they come to see him
but they came out loving me you know
what I mean they came to see him but
they came out and remembered me that
should be always your mentality when
you're making that transition from the
point of you just sitting there just
finish doing you know comedy cuz see in
the beginning you just working on your
craft at some point you got your craft
now how do I manifest it together to
package it up so I can expand it for
everybody else to see it and just doing
meaningfully show meaningless shows just
to be doing it it hurts you in my humble
opinion yeah so what um I mean know
which what what advice would you have
for me Quake what what what would you
what would you bestow upon me with what
we have here with this show and my
standup like Implement both of them to
it you have a great platform you're
funny because I watched you just
continue to get with other comics and
have your people sit here and say I want
to work with other strong comedians I
need higher platforms on bigger shows
and then you tell them dad that money is
negotiable stay get me if you can get
retail get it but if it's off retail I
get it because I'm trying to expand my
base and that's how you keep doing then
you say I seen them on Quake show I seen
them on Quake house I heard them on the
just keep on working with other positive
comedians positive Comedians and and put
your brand together and you'll grow and
then you can learn too by seeing it oh
see that's why my joke ain't work I
should have put more emphasis on this
you learn with other great Comics you
learn oh so when I get a when you do a
bit like okay I want to do this bit and
be perfect the way to do it like on airs
did it you know and you're not biting
off is what it is but you do take off
the point of say this is how he did it
you know what I mean now this material
if I do this material I got and do it in
the in the in the package like he did it
then it is off of it then you you know
you learn from steel Sho and steel and
you get to learn off of it like Kobe
said man he watch Mike that's how you do
it that's how you back in man give him
the shoulder to the left back to the
right and that's how you do it like that
that's all I think that's I'm currently
in a comfort zone of like I've gotten
some road work and things like that but
I'm not really surrounding myself with
like higher like Ians that Ru like you
said steel starp Sharp and steel yeah
and you want to do that you know what I
mean you want to do um a lot of times
you see it the best way I got into it
was um they do a lot of benefits you
know um they do a lot of uh different um
festivals you know you see these
Festival go out the J for Laughs the
Southwest all of these things you he
your people say man y'all need to put me
on I take the first five
cuz see I tell people all the time man
um there's not a comedy club a comedy
show in the world that starts on
time the best will start 15 minutes late
there go 15 minutes right
there they go 15 minutes right there now
yeah you are at an adverse situation
people coming there but if you get those
first right there it is sharing you so
much so when you are the anchor you are
ready you already shown your material
can wait just getting there just sitting
there and they paying no attention you
killing right then God help you when you
you you number three number four number
five and then it'll make you appreciate
the three to Fourth position because you
and you will have empathy for the
brother who's in number one CU that used
to be you you know what I mean it's a
growth it's a process but you want to be
around it and then you get to what I did
was sit back and see how professionals
did it like okay I'm going emulate that
when it's my turn I ain't gonna do that
you understand yeah that's that's cool
okay I'm GNA need that I ain't GNA be
that that's I ain't gonna be no ass like
that you know what I mean you get to you
get to sit back and ain't nobody
noticing you you know what I mean cuz
whatever way they going to do they [__]
they they gonna do it in front of you
cuz you ain't a star yet see when I get
around they going temper their [__]
attitude and put on the show like that
but for you when I was down like that I
could just sit back and see how they
treated Steve Hy see how they treat
Bernie Mack see how they treat Martin
lawr see how they treat that see how
people did often see what you supposed
to get when you become Martin loss see
what you supposed to get when you become
bur see what you how they don't supposed
to treat you when you burn it see how
you just get to learn and you just get
to see it see I show okay when I get my
show I ain't gonna have four people open
for me I'mma have three I'mma have four
I'm have a d I'mma give a break to a
young comedian let them say hey man 801
get on stage stay on there to the show
and kill them right here you can go with
me all the time got a high 500 per show
for you all the way through put you up
everything you can be down you be in all
the photos everything on it 30 city tour
you could be on it and you give back on
it and then you can sit back and you'll
say just sit back and just look and
you'll see how the game is played and
that's that's the best internship you
can get you know that's bars you know
best internship you can get and then
when it's your turn you already know how
you want your [__] to roll you being
around the greats is there like a common
trait of theirs that you've picked up on
that kind of separates
them oh that's a good question
um they were all
talented no man I mean you is
no you can't beat their
talented people I mean that's back to
your question about the Instagram being
know
comedi I
mean eventually you G have to show that
Talent
obiously
you you you understand you Bally you
going to have to show that goddamn
Talent you going to have to show that
you're a talented guy and all of them
was extremely talent and you sit back
like oh
God and it it certain people get
inferior I mean get scared of it but
certain people motivation you you like
all
right c m you like hey I'm working with
this person I got make sure I I get my
proper sleep and I got to be ready cuz
you know this [__] going bring
it and if you got to go behind him you
got to be aware that you got to bring it
and and the best thing I tell comedians
to you want to be funny cuz if you know
the technique you can ride that wave of
laughter he had and it can take you
through your whole set but if you fight
it going fight yourself in one of them
rip currents and get drowned
tital wave
yeah help me Jesus Oh Lord Oh Lord oh
you drown in flop sweat up there when it
go well exactly E A LIF gu I'm my boy
they give him the life yeah come on come
on out there
fell I know you got 20 minutes but we
just need that five get out of that rock
come on out of there Rock going to get
your it's going to Bubba you've been
fighting bums all your life down in
marota Georgia
you're not ready about you was it was
cans they was they was all cans tuna
cans rock you understand you think you
beat him we put all them people there to
laugh at your stuff right you was all on
Instagram you really thought you was
killing we bought them followers
[Laughter]
Rock we bought them likes rock yeah that
boy going bub you don't have a
chance let's land This Plane here my
friend cuz no I mean you cool leten I
just check my what name but you all
right cuz I know we're we're I'm about
to be on your radio show yes quak I'm
want show he serious ex very proud of it
five years Ed it
um it's been a beautiful thing I think
um just [__] I just bought this goddamn
goddamn you sound like a grandpa looking
at his Apple I just this mother yeah I
had a Fitbit watch but I went on and
upgrade it got the Apple watch now they
got security all in my house and this
telling me [__] cameras on Bo
and everything boy new tax bracket you
just sold out that theater in DC now
it's new tax bracket it was so beautiful
I wish this for every comic Kevin had it
when he did it in Philly of course
Steve Dave but [__] Dave this
[__] had a whole week in New
York at Madison Square Garden he sold
out Madison Square Garden for the whole
[__] week for his birthday Tuesday
Wednesday then we they had the party on
Thursday then he sold it out
fridayy I mean I'm I'm not talking about
the theater talking about the
Gardon and you just look at it and it's
a motivating thing you know and I set up
I said okay I said this is where I want
to be this is where I should be how do I
get here and that's all the thing I'm
into now you know what I mean it's a
beautiful thing so you start at the MGM
in Washington DC selling that out and
then um two more things with a um uh
live nection and you know they checks
are good walked in there they ain't even
have a hole on it yeah soon as I gave it
to the Mike said
certainly certainly sir none of that let
me holler at you no after the show yeah
they paid me the most money I've ever
made on doing stand up in my career for
one night I mean live stand up not
specials or stuff like that but actually
standing on stage and doing it that's
the most money I've ever made ever just
this past week what does that feel like
after over 30 years validation yeah
especially at home validation that yeah
okay I made it it's here it's happening
it's coming to the wish even though I
never you know sit here and like I just
put the work in and whatever came I was
so grateful for it but it's a humbling
his bre like okay it's a chance that I
can it's going to happen that I'm gonna
you know what I mean you know
internationally because I did it over
there with Dave and Chris Rock over in
Europe and been a fantastic then come
back to sell yours and it's just you I
tell comedian you you make it and you
could put your name on any billboard and
somebody stop and go in there and buy a
tickets specially just to see you that's
when you made it you know what I mean
not paper the room not this but they
actually came and said
hey I'm paying my money to come to see
you and uh to do it for over you know
3,200 people and that theater was just
remarkable and
and in front of your hometown and from
all your friends that you grew up with
family friends and none of them knew I
was of comedian because I didn't start
in DC I started in Atlanta and none of
them knew me by earthquake I just came
up with the name earthquake in case this
[__] didn't work yeah you know what I'm
saying I ain't want to mess up my real
good name you know we go home do you
know this [__] got out the Air
Force and went to Atlanta to try to be a
comedian no man that [__] was
terrible down he think we don't know
about it so if it didn't work out I
could still go back home and then nobody
knows so somebody come hey what your
name Earth I no damn earthquake man my
name naani you you know what I'm saying
so fortunately with the grace of God it
did work out so
nobody family friends new earthquake
they could acquain it with me until I
actually got on TV and the rest of they
Hey cuz I never call my family or none
of them and told them I was a comedian I
never none of that cuz you know I have a
brothers and sisters they go harder and
they have no cut card so I had to really
be good before I allow them
[__] come see me and then when
they came to see me they're like n he
really is good he's funny he really is
so once I got the approval from there
then I told everybody else that's what I
you started in white rooms right yes all
white people yes I started with white
clubs I did all white clubs in the
beginning
and um when I um I couldn't get into the
black comedy club so I was the exact
opposite I was in front of all black
people CU I can't get all the all white
clubs oh yeah they're racist yeah racist
yeah they wouldn't let us and they was
so structured you know what I mean you
know what I mean you had managers
telling you these were jokes you
couldn't say and this you were [__]
manager of a Kam Club you don't know the
gift mother he was just waitress two
weeks ago you know what I'm saying you
was the you was just a food Runner you
understand now the all a sudden you over
here telling who got the gift and who
don't [__] out of here but you couldn't
say that and say all right I wouldn't
say that but they just made you stronger
but what white clubs did do for me it
gave me
discipline 15 minutes was 15 minutes 10
minutes is 10 minutes 20 minutes is 20
minutes
black clubes 20 minutes is 30 minutes
had to drag the [__] off the
state I used to be in there like a white
dude his time is up the [__] how the
[__] is he doing 30 minutes and he only
supposed to do
20 it was a it was a shock I was like
what the [__] kind of [__] this some
[__] man he only supposed to do 15
minutes man he up there 35 minutes this
[__] would never happen at the Funny
Bone right you'll never work again that
wasjust doing black or them
[__] was one undisciplined ass
[__] comedians was UND disipline
like [__] and it just didn't you'll go
to the manager and Sh man the [__] why
you even got a goddamn
schedule you know what I mean you come
you suppos me on at 8:00 you don't go
until 9 cuz the other two [__]
they 40 minutes and he threaten you
ain't going to work in nowh next week
this [__] right there working
again it was [__] up well you made it
yes thank God now you're getting the hot
breath bump so I think it's it's on the
up and up for you there Quake yes that I
made this is officially let me know that
I'm I'm certified and I I appreciate you
taking time to do this because we were
going to do it in Atlanta and then I had
equipment malfunctions and you were
gracious enough to be like well let's
we'll do it the right way and then yes I
flew out I I moved a flight for this
well listen I was like let's make it
happen well you deserve that um I'm
always going to support supp you I
support the genre that we do I also
believe it's important that people in my
position get to this position you want
to I'm not telling them not do the
highend different you know the different
the tonight showing but you got to give
to people such as yourself who loves
this genre that keeps it going and I
will always support you and I'm always a
phone call away my brother well qu
appreciate you being on hot breath my
friend thank you man for having
me
comedy
history hot breath